[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIEL LANGER: My
name is Daniel Langer.
I'm a product
manager at Datadog.
I'm joined by
Michael McClintock,
who's a senior systems
administrator at Marketo.
Just to give a brief
overview of what
we're going to talk about
today, just so everyone knows.
We're going to talk a
little bit about monitoring,
how we think about monitoring
at Datadog, some best
practices, what monitoring is
all about if you haven't really
dug into it before.
We'll talk a little
bit about the change
from on-prem to these
dynamic cloud environments
and how monitoring has
changed throughout.
And then I'll pass
it over to Michael,
and he'll dive deeper
into Marketo's story,
their migration from on-prem to
Google, and how they monitored,
along the way, using Datadog.
And we'll leave plenty
of time at the end
for any questions you may have.
So this is a three-party
migration story.
It involves Marketo.
They're the ones who
actually migrated.
But Google Cloud was very
involved, along the way,
as you'll hear
later from Michael.
And Datadog played a part
in aiding that, as well.
So for those of you who
don't know what Datadog is,
we are a SaaS-based
monitoring solution.
We collect information
from your infrastructure,
from your application,
from logs.
We create awesome timeseries,
dashboards, and alerts,
so that you can get notified
when things are going wrong
and get to the bottom
of issues, immediately.
We have over 250
vendor-supported integrations,
with all the popular services
that you might be using
to power your infrastructure.
Also, we're hiring.
And if you want to learn more
about open roles we have,
feel free to chat with me after.
So not too long
ago, I was in Japan.
And as anyone does in
Japan, they go get sushi.
And I went to a pretty
unique sushi restaurant
in the style of a conveyor
belt. And how it works
is you take your seat.
And there's this big,
rotating conveyor
belt, where sushi chefs are
preparing sushi and placing it
on the conveyor belt. And
eventually, it comes around
to the table in front of you.
And you could pick
it up and eat it.
You could also order
specialty items,
and the chefs will
make it, and it'll
come around and make a little
sound when it's your item,
and you can pick it up.
And because I live and
breathe and eat monitoring,
I started to think,
now how would you
monitor this type of operation?
And it got me thinking.
And it made me realize that
this type of restaurant
isn't too far off from a
website or a web server,
where you're making requests for
sushi, and you get sushi back.
And it made me think,
wow, this is really
in parallel to how we think
about monitoring at Datadog.
So how do we think
about monitoring?
Well, we break it into
three unique parts.
We have what's
called work metrics,
and these are the set of
metrics that are directly
impacting your end users.
They are things like
throughput, successes, errors,
how long things are taking.
So if we think about
the sushi example,
throughput might be how quickly
sushi is entering the conveyor
belt, right?
What's the number
of sushi pieces
entering that conveyor
belt per second?
What are the number of
correctly made sushi pieces
versus incorrectly made?
And finally, how long
does it take for customers
to get that piece of sushi
after they ordered it?
What's that latency?
And again, these are those set
of metrics that are directly
impacting your user experience
and ones that your user
immediately notices.
Under the hood, though, there's
a set of resource metrics.
And these are the
things that are powering
your system under the hood.
So they're things like
utilization, saturation,
errors, and availability.
And to put this into
context, utilization
might be how busy are
the chefs and how big
is their backlog of items
that they have to prepare?
How many pieces of the raw
ingredients do they have?
Are they out of tuna?
Are they out of rice?
How much do they
have to work with?
Customers might not notice
these immediately, right?
They're not
customer-impacting metrics,
but they very well might be
the root cause of issues.
And finally, there's events.
These are context-rich
sources of information
that occur at a point in time.
So I have those
examples, a code change.
You might be configuring
something differently
and push a change.
You might spin up
new infrastructure.
Any of these things
are events that
might have an impact on
your operations, right?
So a chef quitting, a knife
breaking, a machine breaking,
any of these things could
impact your operations.
So we put it into the
example of a modern system
that you might recognize.
We can look at RabbitMQ, which
is a popular, open source
messaging system for sending
messages across systems.
Those work metrics are
going to be the ones
that your developers
or that your end users
might actually notice, how big
is the queue of messages that
are lining up, how many
unacknowledged messages are
there, things along that nature.
Under the hood, though,
there's something
powering these queues.
There's CPU.
There's memory.
There's network.
There's compute resources
that are actually
powering this queue system.
And then, finally, there's
events that might occur.
You might push code changes.
You might update
configuration, all these things
could affect the
performance of these queues.
So great, we're collecting these
different types of metrics.
We are looking at events.
We're centralizing
it into one place.
But we want to get notified
when things go wrong.
We don't want to notice things,
on a dashboard, hours later.
We want to get notified the
moment something arises,
so that we can take action.
So how should we think about
alerting and notification?
So the way we think about
it is we want to page
or get notified on those
work metrics, the metrics
that our customers
are directly--
that directly
affect the customer.
The latency, right?
The sushi is taking longer
to get to customers.
Let's get alerted on that.
The number of incorrect
pieces that our customers are
receiving has doubled.
Let's get alerted on that.
Once you receive
those, you can then
dig into those resource metrics
behind the hood, those ones
that are powering the system,
and figure out what's going on.
And then you could
also take a look
at the events that have
occurred in that time frame.
Maybe an event caused a change
that impacted your bottom line
and affected your
customers directly.
And the reason we think about
alerting on those work metrics,
the ones that directly
impact the customer and not
necessarily the
resource metrics,
is the resource metrics don't
always tell you the full story.
So if we think about
our sushi example,
getting notified that the
amount of tuna we have in stock
might be useful at 5:00
PM before the dinner rush.
But at midnight
or 3:00 AM, you've
just got paged
for something that
might be unnecessary and
interrupt your sleep.
So we like to think about
those customer-facing metrics.
So let's talk about alerting in
the context of on-premise data
centers.
These data centers
are more static.
You have a set of
servers in a data center,
somewhere, that you've
allocated for your application.
And when it comes to
alerting on those servers,
it's a very
host-centric ideology.
You know you might write these
checks or these notifications
when a server is
having a problem.
So in this example, we
have four servers running,
and we have four
alerts that notify us
when each of these
servers is going down.
At a scale of four,
everything might be OK.
We've written the checks.
Everything's OK.
But then what
happens if you want
to spin up a new server, right?
You've outgrown
your data center,
and you've
architected a new one.
Well then you have to add a
new alert for this server.
So let's do that.
But wait, actually,
we realize we
need to spin up one
more server, and we
need to add one more
server to our data center.
So it's added an alert to that.
And as you can see, as
you continue growing,
this host-centric model becomes
an extremely manual process,
because you have
to continue adding
these host-centric
alerts to them
in order to have full coverage.
And what's more is you only
have that really host-centric
information.
You might get notified
that a host is down
or a host is having
problems or a server
is having problems,
but then what?
That's only a small
sliver of the story.
You might have an
entire environment,
with databases and web
servers and who knows what,
but you're only
getting notified when
the server is having issues.
But things are changing.
We're moving into dynamic
infrastructures, where you're
writing microservices across
regions and availability zones
and using containers that spin
up and down and disappear.
And you don't always know
what's running at one time.
So how do you monitor
something like this,
where it isn't static
and it's ever-changing?
And the answer is tags.
So tags are key value pairs that
provide context and information
about all the different
pieces in your infrastructure.
So if we look at
the Google console,
right here, we have a
few machines running.
And we'll notice a few sets
of important information
that we consider tags.
So we see a Zone.
We see a Machine Type.
We see a Network.
And we see those labels that
are applied to each machine.
All of these are
context-rich tags
that give us information about
the infrastructure, itself.
And what it lets us do
is create data points.
So we can collect metrics from
all these various sources.
So we can have a metric
that might be something
like a bytes received.
We can have a value, how many
bytes we actually received.
When did it happen?
And then we can add the
where did it come from.
It came from a certain zone.
It came from a certain
machine type, a hostname,
a certain role, a
team, an environment.
And then you can have context
around these data points,
so that you can do
things like this.
Now I want you to imagine,
each one of these cubes
has some data point
in it, a number that
could be the number of errors.
On each cube is a set of
tags that describe that cube.
It's a combination of a machine
type, a zone, and a role.
And these are all machines
that might be bundled up.
And what you can do is start
to group, splice and dice,
and filter this data in a
way that's important to you
based on these tags.
So, for instance, if we wanted
to get those three purple cubes
across the middle,
we'd say, OK, show
me all of the data for
us-east1-a and machine type
highmem-2.
And it can return you all the
metrics for that exact criteria
of data.
And what does this let you do?
Well, one, it lets you move
from a host-centric model
of alerting to service-centric
model of alerting.
And I want you to
imagine a scenario
where you have a group of
Google Compute Engines that all
have some common tag.
Say it's zone.
These are all in a similar zone.
And right now, we
have one alert that's
monitoring all of the
machines in this one zone.
So if you spin up a
new group of instances,
say, you autoscale up,
you need more capacity,
and those machines
are in the same zone,
well, your alert
already covers that.
It's looking for that
zone tag and saying,
I'm alerting on all
things in that zone.
If new hosts get spun
up with that same zone,
I can automatically
alert on them.
You don't need to manually
add any new alerts.
There's nothing to configure.
Alerting just works.
And if we go back to our
small example of RabbitMQ,
and we look at it
quickly in Datadog,
this is an example of creating
that type of alert in Datadog.
And what we're looking
at is the number
of messages coming from
each one of our queues.
And it's only looking
in one particular zone,
that us-central zone.
So we have four queues there.
It's split up by name.
And if any of the
number of messages,
in any of these queues,
reaches 10, we get alerted.
So if we create a new queue
in zone us-central1-b,
it'll automatically applied
to this alert group.
And you can get notified
and take action right away.
So that's a brief
foray into monitoring,
what we think about monitoring,
how we approach monitoring,
and how monitoring is changing
as infrastructure is changing.
I'm now going to pass
it off to Michael,
who's going to talk more about
Marketo and their migration
journey.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL MCCLINTOCK: Thank you.
Can you all hear me?
Yep.
Great.
So I'm Michael.
I am a senior systems
administrator with Marketo.
I'm working out of
our Dublin office
in EMEA, hence the funny accent.
I work with Marketo.
And we are a customer
engagement platform.
So what we do is we do
marketing automation.
And I'm not a
salesman, so if you
want to know more about
customer engagement
and how Marketo can
help you improve
the way you engage
with your customers,
we have a stand
right over there.
So you have no excuse not to go
on your way out of this talk.
What's really important on
this slide, that you should
have a look at, is that we
grew by 30% with our revenue
in 2017.
And so that caused us
some scaling issues.
And so we encountered
the on-premise issues
that you will have
heard at talks
right across this
conference this week.
And so we made a decision
to partner with GCP
and to move our
infrastructure to Google.
So the sort of issues
we were having,
that we were looking to
fix with a move to GCP
were scalability issues
and flexibility issues.
But we were also having
some issues with monitoring.
So while we investigated
and embarked
on a journey to
move to GCP, we also
decided to change the way that
we monitor our applications.
So the sort of issues that we
were having on the monitoring
side is that we
had multiple tools
to monitor the same things.
So we had different messages.
We had different thresholds.
We had different teams, who
were seeing different noise
from different monitoring tools.
And that didn't work for us.
And so what we decided to do was
try and group everyone together
and start using Datadog.
So what we began
with, in our GCP move,
is that we had to make a
decision on how to move
our infrastructure to GCP.
And so we had this
sort of discussion,
that I'm sure everyone
will have considered,
which is that we either
would take a lift and shift
approach, which was to
make our infrastructure,
within GCP, work
for our application,
or we'd take a
transformational approach
and make our application
work within GCP.
And there's loads and loads of
upsides and downsides to this,
right?
There is no silver bullet.
There's no objectively
correct answer.
And what we decided to do
is we would lift and shift
our application as the first
phase of our migration.
And so we embarked
on phase one, which
has now been completed as part
of a three-phase migration
to GCP.
So next year, when
you come back,
we can talk a bit more
about the other two phases.
And as part of that, we also
got to work really closely
with GCP.
So we partnered with Google.
And we got to work
with their CRE
team, which has been fantastic.
And we got to get
Google staff on-site
to tell us a little bit of
best practices of running
applications in the cloud.
If you want to know more
about the CRE transition story
that we did, tomorrow,
in the 5th Nine Lounge,
which is just
downstairs, on level 2,
we are going to have a talk
from Cindy Kim just about that.
So why did we go with Datadog?
Well, as we started moving away
from our own infrastructure,
it made sense for us to
take our monitoring out
of our infrastructure, as well.
And so a SaaS-based
solution worked for us.
We also were able to take
advantage of those preexisting
integrations within Datadog.
And so we were able to get
rich, deep metrics about GCP
from day one, without
needing our engineers
to go in and create
those metrics
and start working out
ways to record that.
And also, we really, really
liked the customer check
writing within Datadog.
So the agent, itself,
is Python-based
and checks can be
written pretty simply.
And because you have
access to all of the checks
that they provided, you get
some really good best practice
in the code that's shipping
and that you're deploying
to your service already.
So what we decided to
do, when we pushed it,
is we used Puppet to push it
across our infrastructure.
You could push Datadog,
the agent, itself,
you could push it within a day.
I don't know if you
should, but you could.
You could do it, because
all you really have to do
is push the agent and
start the service.
And as long as you've
got the API key there,
you'll see your
metrics, straightaway.
And that was really,
really useful for us.
It was able to give
us a situation where
we could do a proof of concept
with Datadog really, really
quickly.
And then what we did was--
I'll talk a little bit about
how easy it was later--
but we configured
our Google Cloud
integration within
Datadog, which
allowed us to start getting
information about resources
that we were using within GCP.
And then we started
the arduous journey
of converting our existing
monitoring solution
and moving our infrastructure,
our monitoring into Datadog,
which involved moving
over 1,000 Nagios checks.
And if you have questions
about how to go through that,
absolutely come up at the
end, and we can talk about it.
Because it's fun.
We introduced Google
Spanner, as well.
And this is a
really good example
of where the Google integration
helped us, straightaway.
So Google Spanner was something
that we started using.
And thanks to Datadog,
we were able to get
deep metrics of
how Spanner works
and what we were doing in our
usage of Spanner, straightaway.
So even though we were
lifting and shifting
all of our applications, on
any part of our application
where we decide to do
some transformation,
we were able to use Datadog,
straightaway, and not
have to worry
about these changes
as we iterated our application.
So here's an example
of-- or we could just
talk quickly about
how you would monitor
a migration with Datadog.
So thanks to what Daniel was
talking about, with tagging,
we were able to effectively
monitor our old infrastructure
and our new infrastructure,
side by side,
and quickly group by whether a
server is in GCP, for example,
or what version of
code we're running
or which, I guess, zones and
geographical information, as
well.
And what that meant was that,
pretty much, from day one,
if you're taking a lift
and shift approach,
you're able to see
how the performance
of your application, within GCP,
matches with your performance
on-prem.
And that's really
useful information,
because you can find
out if you're doing
something wrong pretty quickly.
And you can also
find out if it's
way better than
you were expecting.
And here's an example
of a dashboard.
So you're also able to
provide, to your engineers,
pretty much, very
simply a side by side
view of your
application's performance.
Any code changes they push,
they can see that straightaway.
And it's really easy to
design, so even I can do it.
So other changes
that we implemented
or other initiatives that we
took, as part of this move, we
decided we'd go down an
infrastructure-as-code route,
which meant that we
started using Terraform
to control our GCP environment.
But we didn't want
to stop there.
We wanted to try and use this
philosophy or this approach
everywhere that we could.
So there is actually a Terraform
provider available for Datadog.
And what that means is that
you can control your Datadog
instance with Terraform,
which is great.
Because one of the big concerns
that we had, and, certainly,
if you're considering Datadog,
a concern you might have
is that, if you have
a SaaS solution, which
is fully managed
through a web client,
you're worried about who can
access it, who can change it.
What happens if you
lose your configuration?
click the wrong thing?
If you manage this
with Terraform,
you've got some
really good options.
So, for example, you could just
lock down the entire web client
and make it impossible to manage
the instance through the web
client and make all the
changes go through Terraform.
And what that then
allows you to do
is you can put all
of your changes
to your Datadog environment
through code review.
It effectively acts as
a DR system, as well.
If you lose your
Datadog instance,
you can rebuild
it pretty quickly.
And it allows you to roll back
any bad monitors you introduce,
anything that's too noisy, or
anything that isn't working.
And as part of this
change, we also
changed the way that we
handle incident response.
So this is an ongoing move
that we're making still.
I mean, you could have the best
monitoring system in the world,
but it's kind of useless
if it's not paging you
or if it's paging
you in the wrong way.
And so we started working
with Pagerduty, as well,
as part of this move.
And that allowed us to have
a rules-based, really deep,
powerful pager routing system.
And it allowed us to populate
and pass our Datadog tags
all the way to our
on-call engineer.
So as Daniel was
pointing out, the tags
were one of the most
valuable bits of information
that we were able to add
into our observability.
So we were able to take
a tag from our servers--
so for example, the version
of code that it's running,
the role that the
server is playing within
the application--
and when we page
an on-call engineer
or we wake somebody up, we have
that information right there.
And it's available to everyone.
And so this allowed us
to really improve the way
that we were
conveying information
to our engineers
who were on-call.
And on-call is not
an easy thing to do
or it's not a nice place
to be, so it's always
nice to make it as
easy as possible.
So just as an example
of the sort of ease
of use and quality
of life improvements
that you get out of using
Datadog as part of this,
the Google Cloud integration
is really simple to configure.
You can do it in
minutes, I would say.
So all you really need to do
is you create a service account
within GCP.
And you just make sure
that you're giving it
the correct permissions.
I think we have a slide here.
It's hard to read.
But as long as you've got
monitoring viewer permissions
within that service
account, that account
can pretty much start
giving your information
into your Datadog instance,
straightaway, on day one.
So you just take a
JSON-based private key,
and then you go into
your Datadog instance,
and you just put
that key in place.
And you will start getting
information, straightaway.
And that comes with pre-built
dashboards, so within 15,
20 minutes of starting
to use Datadog and GCP,
you can start seeing all of your
resources, all of your usage,
everything you need on a
dashboard, straightaway.
And this is an example
of the integrations
that you get within Datadog.
So these are the
GCP integrations
that they provide dashboards and
monitoring for, out of the box.
But what's really useful is
that it doesn't stop here.
So Daniel said there's
250-plus integrations, which
means any
application-- if you're
using an application that's
widely used, almost certainly,
there's some form of
integration in there.
And if not there, it's
probably on its way.
And if you don't see it,
it's really quite simple
to put that in place yourself.
[MUSIC PLAYING]